my name is Martin Salem and I work in
construction of equipment for a company
called constructive equipment we're
doing it for five years now
started to raise my awareness within my
client base and candidate base and get
people more aware of Who I am and to
engage with candidates and clients
online really I was trying to solve the
problem of not being known or not being
recognized in the market and so trying
to become an expert in my field and
trying to you know be relevant to my
clients and candidates with you know
good content
I've been able to achieve much more of a
presence online and I've been able to
have warmer introductions when talking
to candidates and clients specifically
people that have had contact with in the
past or even new contacts on LinkedIn
really
I recommend it for for many reasons the
main reason is to create an online brand
for yourself where people can obviously
know more about you and what you do and
specifically be more personal to you to
yourself really